we are it was just something that kind  of came to me kind of happened  everything starts to get quite sore  after a while because it's a lot of  repetitive motion  tendons in the connective tendons my  biceps were getting sore and so I had to  warm them up before I threw punches I'd  literally do that to warm them up and  then um I got kind of shy afterwards and  I didn't do it for the next take I said  oh sorry Mickey I won't do that again  he's like do what okay whatever let's go  again and then I did another take  without doing it and then McCue came up  to me and said what are you doing why do  the thing again and I said what thing  came and showed me the monitor I was  like oh okay cool and I was like that  was good  he said yes definitely do that do that  and then we we stuck with it and became  became a thing we looked at that over  and over in rushes I remember the time  like I saw that take it he did that at  the Cure I was like this is awesome  three two one yeah  [Music]